[Music]
we have already seen the characteristics
of images formed by plane mirrors the
image is of the same size as the object
and it's also at the same distance away
from the mirror as the object is and the
image follows left-right reversal it
means that the objects right is the
images left and vice versa and lastly
the image formed by a plane mirror is a
virtual image so what about the image is
formed by concave mirrors do they have
the same characteristics you all must
have seen the reflection of your face in
a spoon spoon has two smooth surfaces
one curved inside and the other curved
outside however it is not perfectly
spherical for ease of understanding we
can consider the reflecting surface
which is curved inwards as a concave
mirror I will show you how the image
appears but using an actual concave
mirror and not a spoon so let's try and
find out the properties of an image
formed by a concave mirror I will show
you two views of the mirror the front
view and the side view the side view is
just to show the different positions
where the object is kept as it's
difficult to do that in the front view
okay so let B be its bowl see it's
center of curvature this line is the
principal axis and the F is the
principal focus also called focal point
assume that initially the object is kept
close to the mirror I will make a table
on the right with three columns telling
us where the object is kept the size of
the image formed and the nature of the
image that is whether the image is
virtual or real so initially the
position of the object is between F and
B what is the size of the image we see
the reflection in the concave mirror and
the image is bigger in size we see that
it's enlarged the dimensions of the
image are greater than the dimensions of
the object so we say that when the
object is between the principal focus
and
the image formed is enlarged also is the
image upright or erect what about the
nature of the image is it real or
virtual yes it's the virtual image it
appears to be formed behind the mirror
where is the location of the image it is
a virtual image so it does not have any
location it only appears to be formed in
a location behind the mirror but we will
find that location in our next video
using ray diagrams for now let's move
the subject away from the mirror and see
how the dimensions and the nature of the
image very relative to the object you
will find that as I move this object
away its image gets even bigger and when
the object is at the principle focus the
image is huge we say that when the
object is at the principle focus the
image is highly enlarged is it a real or
a virtual image it is a real image since
it's a real image it's upside down or we
use the other word for it which is
inverted it is formed on the same side
of the mirror as the object is and
believe it or not the image is actually
formed infinitely far away when I start
moving this object away from the focal
point towards point C the image is still
enlarged but the size is reducing and
what is the nature of this image yes
here as well the image is upside down
it's a real image when the object is at
Point C the image is still real and
inverted
but now the size of the object and its
image is same yes at this point both the
object and the image are of the same
size what next
if I move this object beyond Point C the
image remains real and inverted but now
the size of the image is actually
smaller compared to the size of the
object so we say that the image is
diminished this is also a real image as
the objects keep moving beyond C
the size of the image keeps on reducing
what if the object is placed at infinity
well if you remember that in our
previous video we saw that the rays of
light parallel to each other as well as
to the principal axis will converge at
the focal point and in that example our
object was the Sun Sun is at a very
large distance away from the earth and
hence we consider the rays of light from
it reaching the surface of the earth to
be almost parallel the image of the Sun
will be formed at the principal focus
similarly if any object kept infinitely
far away from the mirror on the
principal axis all the rays from it can
be thought of as traveling parallel to
each other after reflection they will
all converge at the focus and the image
of that infinitely far away object will
be formed at this point yes this is the
point size image it's a highly
diminished image and it's also a real
image take a moment and go through the
properties of images again from this
table you can see that the image is
virtual only when the object is kept
between the focal point and the pole
otherwise the image formed is always a
real image in the next video we will
find out the position of these images
using grade diagrams
[Music]